honnête du monde nous sommes du côté des
l'ukraine
et nous essayerons de tout faire pour
défendre l'ukraine merci beaucoup madame
la présidente vice présidente d'être
jolie varsovie merci beaucoup pour une
autre discussion d'aujourd'hui
pour cet échange que nous avons eu tout
à l'heure en face à face est aussi un
des nos délégations nous avons abordé
tous les sujets importants
j'ai souligné
l'importance de l'attitude américaine
j'ai remercié pour tout ce que le
président américain john madden a fait
pour tout ce qu'a fait madame la vice
présidente du discours l'attitude de
dieu congrès américain étant donné qu'il
est nécessaire de mettre en place des
sanctions efficaces contre la russie et
les etats unis sont à la première ligne
des sanctions contre la russie et ses
sanctions fonctionne
merci beaucoup aussi pour tout le
soutien
qu'il a apporté pour l'ukraine qui est
aujourd'hui en luc merci pour l'aide
humanitaire qui est transmise vers
l'ukraine je voudrais aussi remercier en
profitant de la présence de madame la
vice présidente toutes les organisations
humanitaires américaines qui essayent de
s'engager dans l'aide humanitaire
qui veulent fournir des équipements
médicaux
qui veulent assurer les services
médicaux pour les personnes blessées
pour les enfants ma femme agatha est
engagé également dans ce travail qu'elle
coopère avec des organisations
américaines elle est en contact avec
l'épousé du président vanden et je suis
ravi que cette coopération entre la
pologne et les états unis se renforce
je suis surtout ravi que cela sert à
aider tous ceux qui ont besoin de cette
aide qui souffrent aujourd'hui
parlez à madame la vice présidente de la
situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui en pologne depuis plusieurs
jours nous accueillons des réfugiés en
provenance de l'ukraine il y a près de
1,5 million d'ukrainiens qui sont déjà
arrivés en pologne je peux dire avec
fierté que ces personnes ne sont pas
envoyés vers des camps de réfugiés ils
ont trouvé la place au sein des foyers
polonais dans des maisons polonaise ils
ont été accueillis dont des hôtels des
pensions de famille des sanatoriums la
plupart du temps ce sont des polonaises
ordinaire qui apporte cette aide ils
sentent la nécessité de fournir à l'aide
aux ukrainiens qui souffrent aujourd'hui
je voudrais remercier mes compatriotes
pour cela c'est quelque chose qui est
une source de fierté pour les autorités
polonaises je vous suis extrêmement
reconnaissant mais en même temps j'ai
demandé à madame la vice présidente son
soutien puisque on a affaire ici à une
grande crise humanitaire c'est une
surprise pour la pologne c'est une
situation difficile pour la pologne
aujourd'hui face à la crise face à
l'augmentation des prix des carburants
ou de l'énergie
dans cette situation ce soutien est très
nécessaire et je serais très
reconnaissant pour tout ce qui sera
apportée par ce que nous devons
maintenant
persévérer dans nos efforts et des de
nos voisins pour essayer de traverser
cette période difficile nous avons
encore tout abordé des questions liées à
la sécurité la présence de kamala harris
en pologne c'est une autre preuve de la
présence forte des états unis ici en
pologne nous avons des soldats
américains sur place
nous avons des systèmes militaires
américains que nous protège
nous avons aussi
aujourd'hui la vice-présidente des
etats-unis
donc c'est un signal politique très
important qui montre où se passent les
choses importantes aujourd'hui dans le
monde dans l'espace europe 1 nous devons
sauver l'ukraine nous sommes tous
conscients de cela il faut tout faire
pour cela il faut maintenir notre unité
il nous faut agir ensemble au sein de
l'otan
il nous faut la solidarité entre nous il
faut que nous parlions d'une seule et
même voix à la fois au sein de l'union
européenne ils sont de toutes les autres
et organisations nous devons adopter des
sanctions fortes contre la russie nous
ne pouvons pas accepter ce qui
s'apparente un génocide puisque lorsque
on bombarde un hôpital pédiatrique où il
y à des femmes enceintes et des enfants
lorsque des missiles tombent sur des
quartiers d'invitation c'est une
barbarie qui s'apparente au génocide
c'est une tentative d'éliminer toute une
nation c'est pour cela que nous devons
avoir une position forte en tant que
représentant du monde est libre et la
pologne est aux côtés vous etats-unis
sur ce point tout comme tous nos alliés
et comme tous les pays il honnête du
monde en particulier des pays
démocratiques
lors de notre discussion
j'ai également abordé la question du
renforcement de notre sécurité nous
voulons renforcer notre propre sécurité
ici en pologne grâce aux achats
d'équipements militaires grâce aux
programmes qui sont déjà en cours comme
patriote
comme le programme d'achat des chasseurs
f-35 ou encore un programme qui a été
entamée d'achat
chars abrams j'ai demandé à madame la
vice présidente une accélération de ses
programmes d'acquisition puisque nous
voulons que notre armée soit équipé au
plus tôt est ce que nous en avons le
besoin je pense que nous voyons tous
tous comment est la situation
aujourd'hui nous plongera csn effrayante
qui nous parviennent de l'ukraine mais
en même temps ce que nous voyons sur nos
écrans c'est l'héroïsme et la
détermination incroyable de tous les
ukrainiens nous sommes à leurs côtés
nous allons une et soutenir les soutenir
tout en préservant la sécurité de nos
pays ce qui a une grande importance
pognon merci encore une fois madame la
présidente pour votre venue à varsovie
merci d'avoir montré que nous sommes
ensemble et que nous sommes d'une grande
communauté transatlantique de liberté et
la sécurité
merci monsieur le président 12 heures
merci de votre accueil lors des tristes
circonstances vu ce qui se passe en
ukraine notre ami je vous remercie de
votre accueil chaleureux de ses échanges
très constructifs nous avons eu
aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'un dialogue
une amitié qui existe depuis des
générations
j'aimerais m'adresser directement au
peuple polonais
nous avons parlé avec votre président du
fai ce que sous sa direction sous votre
direction qui est extraordinaire le
monde
a vu la pologne a vu les actes le
leadership dont vous avez fait preuve
dont le peuple a fait preuve avec des
actes extraordinaire de générosité et de
bonté nous avons vu les images à la
télévision
nous avons vu des personnes ordinaires
faire des choses extraordinaires
pour appuyer la dignité et le bien-être
de complet étrangers est donc avant tout
je tiens à vous remercier au nom du
peuple américain vous remercie monsieur
le président au nom de notre président
monsieur jobs a donné je tiens à
remercier le peuple polonais pour tout
ce que vous faites chaque jour cela
représente ce qu'il ya de meilleur en
nous
je suis ici nous sommes réunir
aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'une amitié
d'un engagement qui existe depuis
longtemps entre la pologne et les états
unis sur la base de valeurs partagées de
priorités communes je me tiens
aujourd'hui devant vous sur le flanc est
et si nous évoquons
le
contexte de ce flanc s de nos alliés de
l'otan dans la conjoncture actuelle
qu'est ce qui est en jeu aujourd'hui
quels sont les principes directeurs de
l'alliance atlantique et nous évoquons
la question de la défense de la
souveraineté de l'intégrité territoriale
dans le cas de l'ukraine comme le
président du dal a bien décrit depuis
des semaines et rien qu'au cours des
dernières 24 heures nous sommes témoin
d' atrocités inimaginables
une maternité un hôpital pédiatrique
nous avons vu des femmes enceintes qui
étaient là pour se faire soigner
qui étaient prises en charge et qui ont
dû être évacuées
en raison d'un acte de violence qui a
été non provoquées qui est injustifiée
je suis en pologne pour
exprimer
l'importance des relations entre les
états unis et la pologne relations
historiques qui existent depuis
longtemps mais
particulièrement sur la question de
l'ukraine notre position est claire elle
est unifiée nous agirons ensemble en
tout dans le cadre de partenariat avec
solidarité pour appuyer ce qui est
important aujourd'hui en termes de
besoins humanitaires sur le plan de la
sécurité également du peuple ukrainien
avec monsieur le président nous avons
échangé sur de nombreuses questions
liées à notre relation spéciale
nous avons une communauté
polonaise en amérique et qui est très
importante il y a des liens très
particuliers
donc nous comprenons la relation que
nous entretenons sur le plan
diplomatique mais également sur le plan
culturel et ses relations existent
depuis des générations et donc à travers
tout cela est dans l'esprit de ces
relations et de nos engagements comme un
engagement commun en faveur des normes
et des règles internationales
aujourd'hui nous avons évoqué nombre de
questions essentielles et notamment en
ce qui concerne le flanc est
nous avons parlé de ce qui est très
important pour nous dans le cadre des
engagements des états unis notamment
l'article 5 comme je l'aï dit à de
nombreuses reprises je vais le répéter
ici les
l'engagement des etats-unis en faveur de
l'article 5
extrêmement ferme nous sommes prêts à
défendre chaque centimètre du territoire
de l'otan les états unis prennent au
sérieux le fait qu'une attaque contre
un seulement de l'otan c'est une attaque
contre l'ensemble de ses membres
aujourd'hui nous sommes ici pour
réaffirmer cet engagement mais également
pour faire ce qui est nécessaire pour
renforcer nos mesures de soutien à la
pologne et à nos alliés dans le cadre
de l'alliance entre l'otan et l'union
européenne il a notamment la question du
déploiement des troupes nous avons
déployant déployer 4700 que membres des
forces armées et en plus des 5000
membres des forces armées dans le cadre
des rotations
régulières et ordinaire aujourd'hui il y
a le système
de défense de missiles patriot en
pologne aujourd'hui je suis fier de vous
dire que nous avons livré ses systèmes
de défense à la pologne
nous le faisons
appelé et prouver notre engagement en
faveur de la sécurité de nos alliés et
précisément de la pologne
pour ce qui est du peuple ukrainien
ce peuple a souffert énormément et
lorsqu'on parle d' aide humanitaire
cette assistance bien sûr est nécessaire
mais ce qui nous engage
c'est le fait que nous sommes
choqués
les pays civilisés souffre lorsqu'on
voit ce qui est infligé à des femmes des
enfants des grands pères des
grands-mères qui fuit qui quitte ce
qu'ils ont connu toute leur vie et nous
sommes choqués et donc il y à une
assistance militaire qui est en jeu mais
également une assistance humanitaire et
tout cela se fonde sur le fait que nous
soutenons le peuple de l'ukraine qui a
fait preuve d'un courage extraordinaire
et d'une habileté extraordinaires et
également dans sa capacité à lutter
contre
poutine et à résister à l'agression
russe donc aujourd'hui nous annonçons
également
il y à des mesures qui s'imposent donc
il faut fournir une assistance
humanitaire et donc oui nous allons
débourser 50 millions
dollars dans le cadre du programme
alimentaire mondial des nations unies
pour
compléter les efforts en matière d aide
humanitaire et le président du hgd à la
dit très très rapidement la pologne a
accueilli 1,5 million de réfugiés en
provenance d'ukraine supplémentaires et
la charge est extraordinaire pour la
pologne pour le peuple polonais donc
nous continuerons d'appuyer vos efforts
les efforts que vous avez déployés que
le pape polonais a déployé
c'est véritablement admirable nous ne
pouvons que saluer votre générosité nous
sommes heureux également
d'avoir pu faire part des décisions du
congrès américain avec le 13,6 millions
de dollars
pour l'aide humanitaire
et l'assistance en matière de sécurité
qui sera partagée donc en ukraine et
entre les différents membres de cette
région en europe non aujourd'hui il faut
une réponse humanitaire est également
une assistance
relatives à la sécurité je suis très
heureuse de d'affirmer aujourd'hui que
nous avons des
discussions en cours avec la pologne
deux alliés sur l'efficacité des
sanctions aujourd'hui et par la suite
comme les états unis l'ont annoncé le
département de la justice américain a
créé une équipe spéciale une task force
pour faire ce qui s'impose ce qui est
approprié en termes d' enquête relative
à d'éventuelles
activités d'éventuels comportements
répréhensibles il ya également des
mesures qui ciblent les oligarques avec
le président nous avons parlé de
l'efficacité des sanctions jusqu'à
maintenant et nous avons parlé du
courage des mesures audacieuses qui ont
été adoptées dans le cadre de l'alliance
atlantique pour faire ce qui s'impose
pour envoyer un signal clair sur le fait
que comme nous l'avons promis il y aura
un prix lourd à payer il y aura des
conséquences suite à l'agression de la
russie aujourd'hui la rouble s'effondre
et mais
aujourd'hui on peut voir que la notation
de crédit de la russie
a atteint un niveau extrêmement bas
et comme vous le savez le président des
états unis a également pris la décision
de faire ce qui était nécessaire
en ce qui concerne l'achat de pétrole
russe aux etats-unis nous
continuerons de nous focaliser sur ces
questions tout en étant conscient
que le contexte actuel appelle des
conséquences lourdes suite à l'agression
russe contre l'ukraine et je conclurai
en disant ce que nous répétons jour
après jour ce que nous avons répété ces
dernières semaines nous sommes aux côtés
du peuple ukrainien nous admirons leur
courage et nous sommes unis dans notre
soutien défense de leur sécurité de leur
souveraineté de leur intégrité
territoriale merci monsieur le président
hibernia poignet ou encore
l'édition polonaise je voudrais poser
une question à la fois à la vice
présidence américaine pour
président polonais comment cette attaque
brutale de la russie a influencé les
relations entre la pologne
les états unis anthony blinken lors de
sa récente visite en pologne a dit que
l'amitié entre la pologne et les états
unis n'a jamais été aussi forte est-ce
que cela va avoir pour conséquence une
présence militaire permanente américaine
en pologne
le répéter assez la relation entre les
états unis et la pologne est une
relation très forte qui remonte à loin
et qui va se renforcer encore davantage
le notamment lorsqu'on fait face à une
situation comme celle d'aujourd'hui
un comportement agressif
et c'est ainsi qu'on peut mesurer la
force d'une d'une relation est ce qu'on
a pu voir cela ne fait aucun doute c'est
que cette amitié ses liens entre les
états unis et la pologne sont très forts
mesdames et messieurs
pour répondre à cette question il
faudrait aller plus loin
ce fonctionnement lorsque
j'ai commencé mon mandat de président
de la république de pologne en 2015
je ne rendait parfaitement compte
j'ai fait
la russie
ne va pas
s'arrêter
à ce qu'elle a déjà fait en 2008 en
géorgie au ensuite en ukraine je savais
très bien que l'appétit à
impériale de la russie va aller en
grandissant si le monde ne réagit pas je
savais que nous allions
arrêter cela s'il n'y avait pas une
grande détermination de la part des pays
de l'otan et la pologne
pourrait
en subir les conséquences donc en
commençant au monde mandat de président
je savais qu'il fallait que je fasse
tout pour prévenir une telle situation
un tel scénario
et je dois dire ici très clairement
que ce sont justement les représentants
des états unis qui comprenait très bien
ce point de vue c'était les vraies
présentant du
las de l'administration du président
obama
c'est le président lui-même ce sont les
généraux américains qui étaient de cet
avis c'est grâce à eux que nous avons
obtenu le renforcement du flanc oriental
de l'otan pour la première fois depuis
notre adhésion au traité de l'atlantique
du nord
c'est au cours du sommet de l'otan à
varsovie que certaines décisions ont été
prises grâce à la position américaine
mais aussi grâce à la position de nos
autres alliés et donc nous avons
renforcé
le flanc oriental et les soldats
américains sont arrivés sur le
territoire de la pologne ils sont
présents d'une manière permanente même
s'il y a une rotation ce ne sont pas
toujours les mêmes soldats qui sont
présents mais l'armée américaine
est ton pologne et c'était effectivement
tournant
je me souviens ce que m'a dit le feu
président polonais lech kaczinsky et en
il m'a dit
au moment où nous aurions les soldats
américains en pologne et l'équipement
militaire en pologne tout le monde
verrait qu'il ne s'agit plus de zone
d'influencé russe
c'est ça le signe d'une véritable amitié
france il dit comme l'a dit très bien
aujourd'hui la vice-présidente
américaine
je suis